two suspects shot and killed tonight in
two different police shootings and both
of them happened just within hours of
each other thanks for joining us here at
11 i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis here's a look at both cases one
near downtown the other in the east
valley orco manoa was on scene at the
first shooting for hours and has more on
what exactly happened
well brian and denise this was a
barricade that turned into a deadly
shooting all unfolding in this
neighborhood the scene here is pretty
quiet now but there's still a metro
police presence police say a man was
firing a gun randomly but luckily no one
was injured some of the bullets did hit
some of the homes in this area police
say that man was eventually killed by
officers after he pointed the gun at
them now the investigation continues
i can hear the little boom sound a scary
situation in this downtown las vegas
neighborhood
police say they got reports of someone
with the gun near 11th and lewis around
9 30 a.m when they got there a man ran
into an abandoned building officers
treated it like a barricade come outside
police are seen trying to get the man to
leave the building in this video taken
and given to me by taminika coates she
says she's friends with the man's sister
it's kind of a sad situation coach says
she saw everything unfold basically
trying to get him out the house before
they had to swat and everything come and
i guess he wouldn't surrender things
escalated when swat came while swat
officers and crisis negotiators were on
scene the subject started to fire
indiscriminately
at the surrounding area metro says the
man shot the gun multiple times but no
one was injured he then aimed at police
pointed his weapon at officers prompting
a swat officer discharged his weapon
striking the subject he died at the
scene neighbors coming home tuesday
night want to see change in the
community being more responsible with
guns not using guns for self gain or
intimidation factors coats now grappling
with grief i haven't seen nothing like
this
the man who died has not been officially
identified yet we hope to learn more
about who he is and what exactly
unfolded here from metro police over the
course of the next few days for now
reporting live from downtown las vegas
tonight orc omana live local now now or